[Music]
in 1976 mafia mafia boss Paul of the
oles in jail for contempt of the court a
local police surveillance operation has
penetrated his inner circle the mobster
is disgraced the oles arch rival the
Sicilian aggressor though quickly
exploits the situation returning from
exile in Venezuela
Rizzuto argues with fellow mobsters that
vo Lee must go getting caught on police
audiotape he says is a breach of the
Mafia's sacred code of silence
omerta but is it cause enough for a
death warrant none of us ever thought
that it was anything wrong with giving
punishment to somebody who have violated
the rules that he swore to uphold
the only caveat to that was that he
better have violated those rules and the
person that gave the order to eliminate
this person better have the proof
killing the boss is a big step one that
can lead to reprisals
still the rank and file are uncertain
Rizzuto makes an appeal to the Bonanno
crime family in New York to sanction the
viola hit the Sicilian went to New York
and New York came investigated and I
guess gave the go-ahead in November 1977
Veolia is released from jail a final
peace meeting with Rizzuto fails On
January 22nd 1978 the Calabria and paolo
alveoli is invited to an evening poker
game at his former headquarters now
owned by a Rizzuto ally he only knows
he's stepping into the Sicilian lion's
den follow you he was going to be
murdered that night
he kissed his wife goodbye
his kid
drove his white Cadillac parked over
there
walked in sat down at the back and
moments later
and that was it
[Music]
Paulo had the biggest funeral the
machine in Montreal chipper mobster the
Bonanno family practically every member
of the five families in New York and
everybody else and his mother was here
fuel his patron Vic cotrona is still the
head of the Montreal mafia but in name
only was backing from the Bonanno family
in New York
Rizzuto takes over day-to-day control
Rizzuto now hosed in Europe family a
favor for approving the viola hit a
favor that one day his family must repay
the Sicilian faction as one
[Music]